Speaker 1: Now let's talk about the timeline.
A little bit like I said, May 2nd is when
the grand jury is expected or planned to be
impaneled, and they're saying they want to
make decisions about whether or not to charge
Donald Trump criminally.
If that is indeed the person that becomes
the focus by the during the first half of
the year, which is June 30th, so you're basically
talking about two months.
Can a grand jury?
Really do everything it needs to do to allow
the D.A. to make a charging decision in just
two months.
Again, in reading opinions from legal analysts
on this, it is possible, but there are legal
and analysts who believe it is far more likely
that the charging decision would come closer
to the November elections.
Now, I'm not even imagining what the repercussions
of that may be, because there's still a lot
of things that have to happen between now
and then.
But this is step one.
Step one is you get the go ahead for the grand
jury, you start sending out subpoenas, you
see who shows up and then you go from there.
So might not be disastrous for Donald Trump.
He does seem to be quite teflon when it comes
to anything that looks at him personally.
But if you're Trump, you would have preferred
the grand jury be rejected rather than approved.
And that's where we are right now.
It has been approved.
Let me know what, if anything, you believe
will come from this.
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
Send me your thoughts.
We'll take a very quick break and be right
back.
As an independently run, progressive media
show, we do depend on people from our audience
to support the work that we do and the easiest
way to do that, the quickest way to do that
and the most direct where the vast majority
of every dollar stays with us is to get a
membership at join Packman dot com.
We do an extra show every day for our members.
You also get commercial free audio and video
feeds of the show, and you get the show every
day.
Six hours earlier than we release it publicly
six hours earlier, that's a big deal.
You can sign up at join Packman dot com.
You can also use the coupon code.
Wow.
22 to save off of the price of a membership.
If you so, please pay full price or not.
We just want as many people involved in supporting
as possible, and you can sign up at join Packman
dot com.
All right, let's talk about something very,
very disturbing.
Not that Joe Biden called a reporter a son
of a bitch.
We'll get to that.
But I'm finding that to be in poor taste,
but not actually scary and disturbing.
The following is scary and disturbing.
Republicans are now openly saying openly saying
if they win the House of Representatives in
November and take control in January of 2023,
they will look to subpoena, potentially prosecute
and maybe imprison members of Congress participating
in the January 6th committee investigating
the Trump riots of last year.
When they say this stuff, we should take them
seriously rather than saying now now when
they told us what they were planning for the
2020 presidential, they did it.
We should have taken it more seriously and
we should be taking this more seriously now.
So I'm going to play a clip for you of Newt
Gingrich.
Newt Gingrich was the speaker of the House
in 1994, ushered in significant acceleration
in the Republican Party's abandonment of policy
and moving into cultural issues and the like.
We've talked about his role in that significantly.
You can check out my interview with Noam Chomsky
where we talk about Newt Gingrich's role.
One of the things that we have heard from
Republicans is that if they win the House
in 2022, they will impeach Joe Biden, and
I believe that they certainly will try.
But here is something extraordinarily dystopian
from Newt Gingrich.
And again, just we have no reason to doubt
him.
Here he is.
Speaker 2: You're going to have a Republican
majority in the House and a Republican majority
in the Senate and all these people who've
been so tough and so mean and so nasty are
going to be delivered subpoenas for every
document, every conversation, every tweet,
every email.
Because I think it's clear that these are
people who are literally just running over
the law, pursuing innocent people, causing
them to spend thousands and thousands of dollars
in legal fees for no justification.
And it's basically a lynch mob.
And unfortunately, the attorney general.
The United States has joined that lynch mob
and is totally misusing the FBI.
And I think when you have a Republican Congress,
this is all going to come crashing down and
the Wolves are going to find out that they're
now sheep and they're the ones who are in
fact going to, I think, face a real risk of
jail for the kind of laws that are breaking
Speaker 1: participating in the duly impaneled
investigation of one of the most disgusting
events of the last five years in the United
States.
If Newt Gingrich got his way and he's not
running, but he's still a powerful figure
in the Republican Party, might put some of
those investigators in jail, folks, when they
tell you what they're going to do or what
they're going to try to do, take them seriously.
That is a lesson from the 2020 presidential
election.
Take them seriously.
Even Republican Congresswoman Liz Cheney issued
a warning over this.
She retweeted the Gingrich video.
We just played and added the comment quote.
A former speaker of the House is threatening
jail time for members of Congress who are
investigating the violent Jan. six attack
on our capital and our Constitution.
This is what it looks like when the rule of
law unravels.
Now, Liz Cheney is one of only two Republicans
on that committee doing the investigation,
so she may feel as though she is now in the
crosshairs and may have a personal interest
in this, for sure.
But this is an idea that Republicans are liking.
Here is video of Matt Gaetz appearing on Real
America's Voice War Room.
This might even be his show.
I'm so confused by this channel.
This may be Matt Gaetz his own show.
Listen to what he had to say about it.
Speaker 2: Now you have the January six event
where I expect that there will be these shadowy
gray area national security types that are
in and around the activation of.
The increase in criminal acuity of that day
and not for nothing, Steve.
But using a cutout seems like exactly what
they were trying to do to me.
Speaker 1: Now note this is all conspiratorial
type stuff about the people doing the investigating
are the ones responsible for the right.
It's crazy, but let's continue to listen because
it tells us what a state of mind is when it
comes to this stuff.
Speaker 2: There's a guy named Steve Alford,
who was sitting in prison right now for trying
to extort me.
But he was not acting alone.
Very likely he was answering to a cutout someone
like Bob Kent to try to destroy me.
Because you know what?
Newt's right.
We are going to take power.
And when we do, it's not going to be the days
of Paul Ryan and Trey Gowdy where the Republicans
go limp wristed, where they lose their backbone
and fail to send a single limp wristed.
Speaker 1: Is that a homophobic phrase?
I'm not super familiar with it, but it strikes
me as potentially homophobic.
Let me know.
Speaker 2: No, it's going to be the days of
Jim Jordan and Matt Gaetz and Marjorie Taylor
Greene.
And you know what?
We're going to get answers, real answers about
about what happened in the election.
Answers about the Wuhan Institute of Virology.
And certainly answers about a Department of
Justice and a national security apparatus
that has gone totally off the rails.
They have become the enforcement wing of the
Democratic Party.
The entire country knows it.
And you know what?
We need honest, fair, real application of
the laws in our country.
We're not getting that now.
And frankly, we weren't really getting it
at the DOJ under President Trump.
There's.
Speaker 1: So listen, you've got to take them
seriously.
Just believe what they're telling you.
If they're telling you they're going to do
this stuff, then we have to listen and we
have to take it seriously because they seem
to really try to do it.
Whether they get away with it is a different
question.
You know, they tried the 2020 stuff.
When you look back and think about 2020, they
tried every aspect of it.
They tried the fake elector stuff.
They tried pressuring local officials.
They tried stopping the count versus starting
the count as convenient to them.
They at least it was in the conversation about
declaring a national emergency slash martial
law, though they'll they'll say they weren't
really close to doing it, which may be true,
but it was part of the discussion.
We know that multiple people have told us
they're telling us what they're going to do
and we have to take it really seriously.
They will try to jail their political adversaries,
and they're admitting that that's what they're
going to try to do.
And we've got to be really, really concerned
about it and not let our guard down in 2022
is particularly consequential because of that.